bir insan karnı doyunca arıza çıkaran
tek canlıdır zannediyorum gidiyorsunuz
Ne demek istediğimi bi her işimiz
yolunda giderken yaptığımız kartlarımız
bile olsa bir şekilde böyle bir soldan
soldan geliyorlar böyle bir şeyler
yaparsınız geliyor bir kapımıza
sığmıyoruz devamlı kendimizi bir zorla
yasımız Var Mutlu edilemeyen bir tür bir
şekilde ihtiyaçlarını karşılaştığınız
bile biyolojik ihtiyaçlarını zihinsel
olarak bir sorun ulaşıyor bu arkadaş ve
bunu insanın fabrika ayarları başlıklı
bir konuşma da anlatmıştım beş tane ayar
saymıştım Bu beş ayar son derece basit
milyonlarca yıllık evrimsel sürecin
bizdeki mirasının sonuçları doğal çoğunu
biliyorsunuz vermişte çok hareket
etmemiz lazım Ve maalesef az yememiz
lazım Lezzetli ama çok ince problem
çıkıyor
o insanlarla iyi ilişkiler koymamız
lazım düşük stresli bir ortam
tasarlamanız lazım kendisi ya da
stresimizi yönetmemiz lazım ve kendimizi
İçinde bulunduğumuz sınırları bir
şekilde zorla mamız lazım Aksi takdirde
mutlu olamıyoruz böyle tuhaf bir türüz
biz ama bugün o gün bahsetmedim
sıfırıncı ayar dediğim çok önemli bir
ayardan bahsedeceğim bu ayarda Kaos
ayarı bu sıfırıncı fabrikaya ben
sonradan bulursunuz önemli anlaşılır
sıfıra yerleştirilince termodinamiğin
sıfırıncı yasası gibi bu da öyle Ne
yaparsan yap cartik yap ne demek
istiyorum sürekli aynı insanlarla
görüşürüz Müsait köyümüz düşüyor devamlı
aynı şeyler yerseniz metabolik Sitesi
geliştiriyorsunuz hayatınızda sürekli
şaşırtmaya sürpriz oyuncak beden ve
beyin ayrılıyor diyor ki bir dakika
Benlik bir şey var ben bir online olayım
Yani ben bir gelişim yeni hücreler
yapayım falan filan Şimdi Kaos böyle
deyince olumsuz bir tavır gibi ya Biz
normalde hayatımızda Kaos sözcüğünü
biraz ve Anarşi düzensizlik kargaşa
belirsizlik falan anlamları
bu Halbuki ckhouse bilimde bambaşka bir
şey tabiatın işletim sistemidir kauss
Mesela işte yazın sıcak kışın soğuk
olacağını bilirsiniz ama önümüzdeki sene
Bugün havanın kaç derece sıcaklıkta
olacağını söyleyebiliriz yağmur mu kar
mı yağacak tahmin edebilmeniz pek mümkün
değildir Çünkü bizim matematiksel
hesaplamalar ımızın erişemediği bir
düzendir havanın düzeni açın cep
telefonunuzu beş günden fazla hava
tahmini alamadığınız göreceksiniz
Neticede ama hava koşulları ya da
tableti kolaylar düzensiz de değildir
belli bir sistem vardır Sadece biz ön
göremeyiz ön göremeyeceğimiz kadar
karmaşık ama düzensiz diyemeyeceğimiz
kadar düzenli olduğu için biz buna Kaos
adı veriyoruz yani tabiat ve bizim
bedenlerimiz bütün canlı bedenler Burada
eğitildi burada yapıldı Biz aslında
kadrosunda Vatan olarak bayağı iyi
tanıyoruz amma velakin tarihsel olarak
bir tercih yaptık Mesela bu resim bence
güzel Anladıysa bir tane ipim şöyle yere
bıraksanız herkes soldaki şekli yapar
ama sadece bakınca diyorsun ya bu
ne var Birisi gelmiş böyle bitmiş etmiş
güvenli hale yaparım En azından falan
diye işe yarayan bir şeye dönüşmüş buysa
biz Sağdaki de düzenliyoruz ve hoşumuza
gidiyorsa bununla bu binaları
Medeniyetleri yapıyoruz soldaki Kaos
marjinal sanatçılar seviyor Sadece öyle
Çok da fazla bizim için bir şeye
benzemiyor sonra bizim tercih yaptık
kendinize düzenli yaşam alanları
oluşturduk şehirler yaptık kaosu tabiata
bıraktık ama pikniğe sürekli Kanka
gitmeye çalışıyoruz yani şehirde bir
davranıyoruz dikkat ettiyseniz şimdi bu
soru işareti Her şey bizim için yapılmış
şehirlerde şehirlerde psikiyatristin
kapılarında Kuyruk var Herkes bir
sıkıntı yaşıyor yani trafiğin bilmem ne
çok düzenli ordu Kuzey Avrupa
ülkelerinde bile intihar oranları
efsaneyi anlatılır biliyorsunuz İnsan
bir davranıyor Yani bir şekilde kaos ve
düzen arasında enteresan bir geçişte
yaptık biz Eskiden tabiatta Muhtemelen
atalarımız Acıkınca yiyorlardı su uykusu
gelince Uyuyordur o çocuğa varsa
koşuyoruz duracağı varsa duruyordu Şimdi
artık
o zaman varsa bu etkinliğin bir saati
var işte billahi bu saatte başlayacağız
ama Türkiye'de olduğumuz tabi gecikmeler
başladı olacak bir yolcu anlatacağım
zaten bugün dışsal bir saatte yetişmek
çok stres yapan bir şey içsen saatinize
yaşadığınızda her şey o fıstık gibi ne
zaman isterseniz öyle yapacaksın zaman
şimdi devamlı dışarıdan bir zaman
yakalamamız gerekiyor Sağdaki arkadaş
Muhtemelen servis bekliyor Saat 4.45
günlük bütün işlemleri bitmiş 15 dakika
sonra servis gelecek ve tamamen işlevsiz
halde Atıl bir vaziyette beklemek
zorunda tabiatta böyle bir şey
yapamazsınız Tabii bazen pikniğe
giderken doktor arkadaşlar metodik
olduğu için piknik programı dağıtıyorlar
bize beraber gittiğimiz pikniklerde 8/35
yola çıkış 905 piknik alanına barıştık
şişte yapılışı 13.30 mangal yeme falan
gibi kavga çıkıyordu Tabi biz piknikte
böyle şeyler yapmak istemiyoruz Canımız
ne zaman isterse o zaman yapmak
istiyoruz fakat dışsal zaman bizi çok
strese sokuyor Dursun modern dünyada biz
Bu bir şey bu eminim hepinizin planları
vardır Bu hafta yapılacaklar Bu yıl
yapılacaklar şirket hedefleri bilmem
neler falan biliyorsunuz ki çoğu
olmayacak Ya biz bu planları yapıyoruz
ama mörfi kanunları her zaman Galip
gelecek bir şekilde işler ters gidecek
Bak söylüyorum bu kadar güzel planlanmış
etkinlik 15'er dakikalık konuşmalar süre
geçiyoruz uçak Akşama görürsünüz planlar
böyledir izmirler Bunu bilir netice
itibariyle Burası biraz daha rahattır o
açıdan netice itibariyle Biz planları
Niye yapıyoruz a ekonomistlere soruyorum
şimdiye kadar kaç kriz gördüm kırklı
yaşların üstündeyse böyle yapıyor ya bir
sürü ve diyorum ne kadar sıkı bir
oluyordu 278 senede bir kesin oluyor
diyorum o zaman yaz takvimi ona göre
pozisyon alalım Niye her krizde sürpriz
olmuş gibi yapıyorsunuz Ne zaman
olacağını bilmiyoruz ya takvime de
yazamıyor Uz hiç kriz olmayacakmış gibi
hiç hasta olmayacakmış gibi hiç ölmeye
ne Yaşıyoruz çünkü belirsizlik bizi çok
strese sokuyor insan türü gibi geleceği
görebilen bir beyne sahip bir canlının
belirsizlik en büyük düşmanı duysa Biz
planları ve programları Aslında önümüzü
görebilme ilizyonu için yapıyoruz Eğer
onların gerçek olduğunu düşünürsek ne
strese giriyoruz benden size tavsiye
plan yapın ama çok da kasmayın Sonuçta
her şey olacak bununla baş edemediğimiz
için devam ediyoruz ki biri bize bir
formül varsa mesela insanın fabrika
ayarlarını yorum Hocam ne yiyelim Allah
aşkına bir şey ne bileyim ben Baksana
bana yani ağzına geleni lan adamım ben
Ben size nasıl formüllerin kendinizin
doktoru olmanızı gerektiren bir dünyada
yaşıyoruz Aslında kendinizin yaşam koçu
kendisini yetişen olmanız gerekiyor ama
biz adımları seviyoruz diye
öngörülemeyen bir de bize öngörü gidecek
Onu yaratıyor bir şekilde diyoruz ya ne
güzel ben bu adamları adımları atarsam
olur ama olmuyor biliyorsunuz Bu adamlar
bir şekilde çalışmıyor tabiata bakar
bu tabiatta hiçbir yolun dümdüz
olmadığını görürüz tabiat karşılıklı
etkileşimler arasındaki barış
antlaşmaları ile yolunu bulan bir sürü
süreçten oluşur ve biz düzenli sistemli
olarak kurduğumuz şu model medeniyette
sağlayamadığınız düzenin katbekat
gelişmiş hali tabiatta rahatlıkla
izliyoruz bir de güzel gözüküyor İşin
kötü tarafı Bizimkiler o kadar da güzel
gözüküyor Biz düzeni de sağlayamıyoruz
estetiği de beceremedik Neden böyle biz
insan niye böyle garip bir turizm insan
olarak size var mı beyin Tabii ki bütün
mevzuyu Benim adım Bence çıktı için
oradan geleceğim mecbur beyin aşırı
gelişmiş çok fazla gelişmiş aşırı
kompresörü şişirilmiş gibi diğer
canlılara göre ama bir şey vardı Şu ön
beyin ayağımızın altında kalan kısım
orası çok fazla gelişmiş ve Bu sistemin
içerisinde pakette gelen bir özellik var
ön Beynimiz Dolayısıyla öleceğini bilen
tek canlıyız
ama Hepimiz öleceğiz
bak bak hiçbir şey olmuyor gibi kişi var
burada Aaa O falan diyen yok Bunu
sallamayan da Tek canlı dikkat ettiniz
mi Hiç ya bir anda silah da yapmışsın
zevkli Geziyorsun yani böyle garip bir
şey insan olmak aslında bir kere bu
büyük bir sıkıntı devamlı öleceğim abi
hemen onu saniye tıpırtı atıp
gidebilirim işte işler ters gidebilir
tamam mı bir endişe var paramı
kaybedeceğim santiyeci alayım biraz
süreyim falan filan hep bunlardan
geliyor Biz zaten o kadar hayvan da
çalıştım çocukluk Trabzonspor hiçbir
hayvan görmedim ya babam bana böyle
yapmasın Ben süper tavşan olurdum falan
yani tavşan olmadı yani Dolayısıyla
geçmiş ve gelecek dertten başka bir şey
Peki bu sistem niye var bize niye benim
de eziyet olsun diye yani endişe travma
bilmem ne hayır bunu verilmesini çok
önemli bir amacı var ve bu amaca yönelik
olarak kullanmak için geliştirmemiz
gereken en önemli şey şimdi odaklanma
becerisi bu iki kanatlı Zihni şimdi
odaklanabilirsiniz geç bir şeyler oluyor
Tabi şimdi diyince genellikle bir kalp
Ne gibi bir daha mı geleceğiz dünyaya
Coşan'ın taşıyalım Kordon'da gezelim
günümüzün edelim gibi olabiliyor madde
köyde değil bir insan parkta Kordon'da
falan yürürken genellikle zihnin hiç
orada değil kitap okurken yaşamışsınız 5
sayfa geçtim de okudum ben falan orada
arsa meselesinde Kafanız gitti Tekrar
dönüp okumanız gerekiyor Bunu bizden
başka yapabilen canlı yok ama köpeğe
bakın mükemmel en orada harika ağaca
bakıyor ağaç koşa bakıyor kuş her şey
muhteşem fakat zihinde süreklilik yok
tam Carpe Diem köpeği ki ağaç sadece
ağaç sonra kuş Sadece bu kedi varsa her
şekilde Sadece kedi O yüzden felsefeci
falan pek çıkmaz köpeklerin arasında pek
rastlamanız böyle birşey Peki insanın
şimdi si nasıl bir şey rahmetli
hatırlarsınız Bob Ross resim sevinci boş
doğanın karşısında geçerli Biz de böyle
maç seyreder gibi abi ne yapacak acaba
falan diye pek tarih Biz bilmiyoruz ya
Abi bir şeyler çizerdim oraya son tam
böyle ağacı Kuşa benzer bir şey olurdu
şimdi buraya mutlaka aç yerleştirildiler
de iyi bak derdik resmi berbat etti
bu otellerde kenarına beyazları bir
arttırdı bir anda üç boyutlu bir ağaç
çıkardı falan resimlerini kazanır bizde
hayretten kendimizden geçerdik ama böyle
işler yapabilirsiniz Zihnine girip
bakabilme becerimiz olsa ya çok iyi
geçmişi göreceğiz başka hiçbir canlıda
yok bu arkadaş boş tuvalin başına
geçtiği zaman bunun gibi insanlar bir o
güne kadar getirdikleri resimle çizimle
beceri ile ilgili beden hareketinin
kontrolü elinde tecrübe varsa geçmişten
hepsini o anda orada bulundurmak zorunda
iki belki beş dakika belki beş gün belki
beş yıl sonra bitecek o resmin Bitmiş
halinin de orada olması gerekiyor
gelecekteki Tahayyül ya da Hedef ya da
Hayal bu ikisinin birleştiği bir zihin
bizden başka hiçbir canlıda yok Eğer bu
ikisini Biz şimdi odakla ya bilirsek
işte o zaman yaratıcı tür dediğimiz şey
ortaya çıkıyor şimdi çocuklarımız da ne
var okulda bir
e Devlet diyoruz deneyim deneyim bilgi
bilgi deneyim dedim çocuğum sen de
olacak Ne bileyim ben KPSS bakacağız
falan hedef yok Tek Kanatlı kuş
salladhor olduğu yerde dönüyor ya da
benim oğlum youtuber olacak kafaya
koymuş Fakat henüz YouTube videosu
çekmedi Oğlum niye yapmadın diyorum Hep
benden daha iyileri var bakıyorum diyor
aklıma bir şey geliyor gerçekmiş hayali
var Çocuğum YouTube'dan milyon kazanacak
ama video çekemediğim için deneyim yok
yine tek kanatlı kuş olduğu yerde dönüp
YouTube tüketici oluyor ikisini birden
doldurmadan bu zihin bizim için
tehlikeli bir bela haline geliyor böyle
bir Zihni tecrübe ve hayalle meşgul edip
şimdi odaklamaz sakp uyuşturma mız
gerekir yapacak başka bir şey yok ve biz
tabiatta bununla hayatta kaldık o
şimdiye odaklan deneyim ve hayal akış
dediğimiz bir zihin durumda ortaya
çıkarıyor ve bizim kaosta dans
edebilmenizi sağlıyor dans edenler bilir
dansta kuralları zorlayamazsınız
algoritmik bir şey değildir
partnerinizin hareketine müjde
o güne göre uyum sağlamanız gerekir
gerçek hayat gerçek başarı gerçek doğum
gerçek insanca yaşamak kaosla dans
etmeyi öğrenmeye gerektiriyor sürekli
düzen içinde yaşayınca da bu
yeteneğimizi gittikçe kaybediyoruz bir
insanın farkı ne sorusuna çok farklı
cevaplar vermeye çalışıyor bunu hep
Çalışacak bu bizim en büyük sorunumuz
binlerce yıldır İnsanın en büyük sorunu
ama bana sorarsanız sadece bilimden
bulamayabilirsiniz bu cevabı Zira yüz
seneden Biraz önce çok ünlü hepinizin
bildiği bir söz Üstadı insana dair bir
tanım yapıyor diyor ki hangi müşküldür
ki Himmet olsun ağsan olmasın hangi
dehşettir ki insandan kira San olmasın
inme Ali'nin verecek olursak Türkçe ama
çok anlayamıyoruz biraz bugün
Türkçesiyle değiştirelim hangi zorluktur
ki birleşip odaklanıp Himmet ödem
ben onu aşama Yalım yani asada olmasın
ve hangi dehşettir hangi korkunç
durumdur ki insanı görünce korkup
kaçmasın bu sözleri söyleyen kişi ki
İstiklal Marşımızın şairi durmayalım
diye bir şiir var okumanızı tavsiye
ederim insanı ve hayatı en güzel anlatan
şehirlerden biri bugün gelecek endişeniz
olabilir çoğunuz yapay zekadan
korkuyoruz bugün kişi çekince duran alet
biliyorsunuz Ay biz ne yapacağız 161 yıl
önce buzul çağı nasıl atlatırsak Bunu da
atlatacağız Yeter ki İnsanoğlu ne
olduğunu bir kez daha Hatırlasın ve
dışarılarda çare aramak yerine dönüp bir
dikkatlice kendisine baksın çok teşekkür
ediyorum